hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see a good day
to die hard
so let's hang the [ __ ] out Ryan's
consensus there is one reason to see a
good day to die hard there is one reason
to see a good day to die hard as a die
hard movie this film is like the worst
die hard movie as a standalone movie it
is one of the worst movies of the year
so far
Sherri's consensus there is a reason to
see this movie there is a reason to see
this movie if you like just carnage upon
carnage upon carnage upon action upon
carnage upon action then you might you
this movie might beat you into
submission reason to see number one
action-packed I never seen this as a
reason to see but it's also one of the
main reasons not to see this movie
but you gotta give it you know the one
little credit it's the one reason to
watch it even if all you want is action
that's all this foam has to offer
there are three actions that using this
movie might not sound like a lot but it
takes up 90 minutes there is a car chase
sequence at the beginning of this movie
that lasts for like 20 whole minutes yes
it does it's like they destroy half of
Russia before John McClane's we even
spent an hour in the fridge country yeah
and the thing that makes this a reason
to see for me is is this because during
that really long J sequence right when
it was about to lose me it did these
things that were just like holy [ __ ] you
just destroyed lots of stuff really cool
so like just as it's about to lose me
with being so much action they'll do
something that just looks [ __ ]
ridiculous it literally is the
definition of non-stop action but when
that's all there is to ha
or it would no not even a hint of
substance just just a little bit of
substance whoo Oh could go a long way in
a movie with this much action just die
hard you know just speaking of die hard
movies it's not just an action film die
hard you know they did yeah there's more
to it than just John McClane killing
countless numbers of people man yeah
well I mean the thing about what what
this the charm of a diner movie to me
seems like I mean a you've got John
McClane who's full of personality happen
to be in these situations where he's
gotta think on his feet he's got clever
he's got to sneak around and you know
use his [ __ ] skills and in this movie
it's just like not just where's the
biggest gun people so it shouldn't be
called diehards yeah it really shouldn't
but you know the action for what it is
is it's certainly action-packed reasons
not to see bad writing directing and
editing oh this one's kind of a blur
it's it's so handheld and I remember the
directors saying that he wanted to shoot
and mainly handheld to capture the
emotion of John McClane that's where
this movie first goes wrong this is not
a John McClane movie this is a Bruce
Willis's son movie and John McClane is
tagging along going why don't you love
me anymore as I was a neglectful father
it's just that the whole time it really
feels like they grab the script that was
floating around and said we're gonna put
John McClane in this and make it die
hard it's like it's just a 90-minute
action fest with John McClane every now
and again gone long vacation
you know the thing that makes divert and
just look at what makes a movie work you
know this this film has like really
lackluster writing it's extremely like
less it's only it's only written as much
as it absolutely has to be to give you a
couple story points to keep it yes and
the directing too just seems such like
oh I want to be Jason Bourne so bad then
okay there are two ways I describe this
movie to my friend walking out of it
it's either the McClane ultimatum or
it's a very special episode of 24
featuring John McClane yeah
because it's all that and I don't even
you know I don't even really mind it in
doses but what the whole movie is like
they're constantly zooming in and they
can't zoom straight they got a good
thing words like yeah I don't either
zero dark thirty pulled it up great yeah
when it's nothing but action it's like
whoa what the [ __ ] is going on in Russia
right now this is a movie this is what I
call like blunt force filmmaking because
it just keeps pounding you in action
until you finally just slump in your
chair and go okay yeah I'm having fun
it's just one big pile of mess like the
action god took a big [ __ ] and out came
a good day to die armed you know those
those moments in cartoons where people
get in fights and like bars and it's
just a cloud and all you see is yes
that's kind of its kind of annoying it's
kind of annoying but at the same time
you might enjoy it reason not to see
number two bad characters the most
disappointing thing about this film to
me is they what did they do John McClane
like John McClane just looks bored
throughout this whole adventure oh yeah
I'm you know another casual or bored
yeah well the only thing he has to do it
really doesn't feel like the script was
written the first time with him even in
it because all he does is are they're
coming to be like son come on you're
you're you're McClane or go I'm on
vacation why do you keep calling me John
that's like the number yeah oh my god
he's just kind of a grumpy badass Jai
Courtney you know the son of Bruce
Willis in this film he's kind of a
grumpy annoying little douchebag son
it's like hey what look what you're
doing right now why are you judging your
dad on how busy he is yeah look at you
right now if you were if something if
you had a shitty day at your job at
Kinkos and then John McClane had to show
up and save your ass maybe we could talk
about this but you're doing the same
thing he does but but more bigger but
you're going across the world breaking
people out of prison like oh my god this
is awful what you're doing seems like a
month into your job you would be like oh
this is what my dad was working a lot
good
takes a lot of work to fight another
thing to the villains and in die hard
movies villains in any action movie
should be interesting there's not really
an interesting villain in this movie I
guess they kind of gave him a court
because he dances and kicks guns around
but other than that he get a carrot you
yeah there's a little waggy that evil
guy but it's not really a special dude
there's nothing interesting about it
there's nothing interesting about any of
these people yeah so there's twists and
turns and so-called surprises but none
of them impact you because we don't give
a [ __ ] about anybody it's like there's
just not enough time for any story to
grab you before they go right back to
action it's like things could have
worked if you you know I'm all for
changing up the formula and bringing
something new but still look back at the
other movies and see what made those
work yeah you got an honor what makes
die hard great and we gotta hang out
with those villains a little bit so that
we can be afraid of them if you're not
gonna give us good villains at least
bring back good old John McClane who we
came to see it's end there anything -
how come the older John McClane gets the
more godlike he becomes seriously the
dude is indestructible
there's one eight he's kind of an
[ __ ] in this movie he goes around
thrashing Russia and he's [ __ ] up all
these cars probably killing countless
lives he's just like sorry didn't mean
to hurt you well yeah and apparently
Russia has no law enforcement no
military no because they're constantly
firing machine guns blowing [ __ ] up like
five cars exploded their helicopters are
shooting at public buildings like and no
one apparently gives a [ __ ] you don't
hear one siren go off there was one in
the background of one scene I think the
sound Department decided to throw that
[ __ ] they have one police guard all of
Russia
what mixed I heard great is when the
characters are reacting to the
situations if you go back to like the
first die hard then man well there's
real fear there because of how John
McClane our hero is reacting or
everything he's swearing he's getting
hurt she does not get hurt in this film
well see yesterday is like at least in
the first three and
the four grunts like by the end of the
movie he looks like [ __ ] he looks like
he's about to fall over and he needs
serious medical attention and this one
yeah there's no they not of not only is
he immune to pain he's immune to
situations yeah apparently nothing makes
the guy go oh wow that's a little
surprising I can just readjust and
starts killing people again in Russia I
feel like John McClane watched all the
die hard movies on the plane to Russia
yeah that's it oh [ __ ] that's what I'm
capable of well I don't care now just
give me a gun and let's do this yeah I'm
gonna play cool and you know you put
John McClane in you in Russia you know
it's weird he's felt more like a fish
out of water in an LA hotel inside oh oh
brand-new country that he's never been
to before
god what a novel film oh but you know
who I did like the taxi driver oh yeah
humor and that was good that's worth
there are two reasons to see this movie
the action and the taxi driver gosh
we're gonna go all out actions at least
provide like hot babes in bikinis then
you know they cut that out of the oh
yeah mercy that's it what happened
that's not really short then wash will
provide more than just gunplay Oh
interesting
it really it really does sort of feel
like a like a be exploitation
you know John McClane ish moving yeah it
could have been like a 10-minute ride at
Universal Studios or something like that
a good day to ride hard it's not a die
hard film it's not it's not not be
called die on it's not even a John
McClane adventure and at the same time
it's just really a bad movie but you can
have a lot of fun I honestly enjoyed it
you've been home talking super bad about
it yeah first I kind of enjoyed it for
some reason for some reason I did have a
good time and yeah I mean it's really
simple and you might find yourself
wishing for Len Wiseman again yeah and
live free or die R but you know I mean
there are some things to enjoy about it
it's uh
that's a weird
subscribe subscribe and tell us your
reasons to see or not to see a good day
to die hard yeah all you Jai Courtney
fans out there yeah Spartacus and people
who've been Russia or if you're Russian
Jack Reacher fans John McClane the fan
and if you like Samuel Jackson he was in
the third one he was I enjoyed him so
subscribe I hope the next one they like
they all yeah they should bring them all
together no you have been haunts to come
back I wanted to be John McClane in all
of his black sidekicks be great you get
the cop and you got Argyle from the
first one and then you got you know Sam
Jackson and then all of his kids they're
all gonna kick ass together and everyone
will change their name to Gennaro and by
the end everyone will be back to the
claim